dollar was knapp ihr sopran ii und heute
gibt es eine veränderung so seine
ankündigung mit der wahrscheinlich
niemand gerechnet hat wir sehen uns
gleich in der runde wieder ja leute wir
sind jetzt angekommen auf der karte und
ich kenne ich hatte glaube ich eine
karte
okay leute wahrscheinlich keine große
überraschung für die meisten von euch
wahrscheinlich keine so große
überraschung will die meisten von euch
denn martin jet sind in einem team
aber jetzt auch von mir noch mal ein
offizielles statement dazu dass wir in
einem team sind und wir werden
hoffentlich ordentlich rasieren alte die
runde ist voll dezimiert schon weil team
grün nicht dabei ist erschreckt haben ja
leute und wir können auch an dieser
stelle schon eine weitere ankündigung
machen nicht nur die in einem spieß team
sind sondern was noch j x gibt es
irgendwas sie trainieren müssen ja also
wir werden erst bei newron war es würde
mir mein bruder trainieren ja als würden
wir karl es sein und dein bruder würde
bei uns trainieren wollen
nun ja wir werden es trainieren also
training mit hauptsächlich dauert
bestehen und dieb ist sprache abzulegen
wie bei den pvp der bereits gut waren
shots die gefeiert
nein du hast du dich denn eben hin
gebaut
ich habe jetzt mal so sagen ich habe
mich zum affen gemacht denn ich wollte
es so selten etwas eisen zum
leute wie gesagt wir werden uns bemühen
ist ein bisschen weniger häufig zu
machen was die sprache und zwar die
andere ankündigung wir sind jetzt nur
einem punkt gekommen
die anwendung ist dass wir eine setzung
skriptsprache ein bisschen abtrainieren
für die richtigen momente und
andererseits werden wir auch einfach so
ein paar trainings sessions machen heißt
einfach mal und anlässlich unseres war
drei teams werden aber mit dieser
tradition brechen und mit dieser
tradition rechnete mit einer tradition
kurzen film wahrscheinlich habe ich ja
doch die rennen dann und wann mal so
wahlparty monaten ihre in zweierteams
machen wir werden es geht vielleicht
auch mal hunger games oder weil
irgendwas ausgeflippt das machen wir
spielen sg als würde es ein spiel geben
an dem wir deinen bruder wegschicken spd
spitze
ich habe noch damals wichtiger wo wir so
eine riesige chaos aufnahme gemacht
haben größer im hintergrund
ich weiß es nicht ich glaube etwas mit
chuck norris und klassenraum
genau diese sprache
diese ausläufer von sprache werden wir
für achtung hinter die hinter dem und
der darf nicht unser gold haben die
stets von 9 11 und tyson lustig
schlimmste reisen verschweißten fomc
macht ich habe etwas für dich dann gehen
wir zusammen auf thema rot macht es ist
so typisch hass und gründer von team rot
dann durch die hand von morgen joggen
wir werden deine ziele so hat man sie
abfällt und du verblühten blumen hin mir
einen duell mit dem hat er einen bogen
michael klenner toccata aus der spitze
lag ihm aber auch schon drei hit gegeben
frostig war es der dem schwert mein
alter ich hasse diesen ob eck sticks man
tut mir nicht gut dass ich sturm frei
hab schon seit ein paar tagen war ich
schreibe in letzter zeit immer sehr um
wenn ich auf nehmt ihr aber zu recht
auch ich habe team rot vernichtet sehr
gut auf dich ist voller seht ihr leute
sitzen nämlich teamwork der anderen ein
andere teams müssen natürlich erst so
zusammen finden aber wir sind einfach
ich glaube das hat man auch schon
mitbekommen dass wir sind zusammen und
ich war gerade eine bahn auf erich
entlang lief da in der mitte fehlte
leider einen blog und ich habe ihn nicht
gesehen und bin leider in die schlucht
gestört ok einfach durchmarschiert junge
weil sonst bekommt okay was sind da los
gewesen ja nicht wenn du geschlagen wird
sie guckt nach oben leute wir haben
perfekt harmonisiert die herausgekommen
nein nein harmonisiert hat nämlich es in
dem video gesagt jemand geschrieben
artikel rausgesucht
ich habe nicht verstanden